tokios spain of course still
an unusual sequence of moves well because it
works like that you can use it directly
well I'm trying my weird
special variant well so that the six
I sometimes play in a similar
position
I'm doing the normal the
normal story that always leads to
that  actually leads to that okay
now a completely different position can
actually always get away from white otherwise
they aren’t
even like that I thought that’s why
it played well back then but here you have to
I think you just have to come for
other moves than you expect
here it wasn't totally stupid
or anything but so yeah that's the
question now can you can you kind of
don't want him to like that he's
already ag 4 silly or maybe
on f3 I'm playing haseks now was my
idea
I can  now in addition to modern springer
the five make
i think i c5
quite unusually quiet so exchange
is the recording
with it 250  now what in between ten
bishops namely the three on
so ordered me to pinch the bishop with
g4
i pull it back over dirt so and now i
have a funny position here with the
pawn on cd but black is
actually quite active in front of everything
I'm now very fast on the line
that pulls there now funny train could
also take but I have good jumps with me
anyway about 2
I'm just wondering if the pretty
hard-looking sugar 5er gt five
runners 525 sanctuary the bilingual
do it three times with  chess alright
let's play let's play simple
and activate around 23
so
on the position threatens
I do here I think yes yes with old man
that chess too no yes she wouldn't have
threatened really safe times now 11 7
from then I have too  always nice that
spot in seventh place
time warner makes or no
well that's what I thought he takes the
final
now i like it very often he
insists that i  also accept
he fulfilled i have now 61
excavations like today namely that is how it
sits a bit of pressure on
the
watch he looks like good but he ca
n’t think of anything
well well two hangs but the four
just want to excavate
77 seconds is of course again  sometimes
very athletic
and i'm lame duck of course
i shouldn't get into similar
difficulties anymore the mood
was so good
his position is yes it's terrible
but maybe i have to play differently here
but somehow maybe play the
king so you eight maybe with it
you could eight years the idea should
provoke at least three times
that somehow that is very
weakened
then maybe c3 somehow
so you have to play a bit differently
i of course also had advantages
but was unpleasant as we didn't have anything
on the clock